I'm ridiculous I'm behind the camera
mouthing every word she said doing her
moves John Travolta is one seriously
proud dad the a-list are stopped by the
talk on Friday with his 19 year old
daughter Ella blue and guys he admitted
that he cannot contain this bride when
he watches his little girl act my wife
Kelly she gets hysterical watching me
watch her because I I just wanted to go
great Ella first shared the screen with
her parents dad John and mom Kelly
Preston in the 2009 flick old dogs so
proud of Ella and Robin Williams was
also in the movie Ella called the shot
on that she was ready to be in a movie
why does all my parents do it so much so
I was just excited yeah is New Orleans
ready now the team is back on the big
screen with her famous pop in the poison
rose and John dished on the tough task
Ella was given on her very first day on
set
poor Ella that she hadn't acted since
their film with Robin and they gave her
the most complicated scene four in the
morning she had to cry hold a gun
consider all sorts of things and she
nailed it and a big applause because it
was you wouldn't give that to anybody to
do it that time but I said well she's on
her own she's got a delivery and all
some kids might be extra nervous
performing in front of their over
successful parents Ella said it was
actually kind of a relief
it helps so much knowing that he was
there and then after and he would come
up in between scenes because I was in a
car so he would come in and then I would
know and I would know that there I had
him behind the monitor just watching and
making sure John is totally a stage dad
you guys how cute is that now if this
cute family dynamic isn't giving you all
the fields yet just you wait because
John who also shares an eight-year-old
son Benjamin with his wife said it
his mission to stay hip I mean at home
we will put on music and dance or at new
year's we had o for hours we were all
dancing and just with to all sorts of
music so it's what's his love and have
you been teaching him any new moves - um
no he's more teaching us I mean even
when like the floss game first came out
he was like look at this video and then
were like oh wow so he sort of
introduced us to that so yeah okay so
his dance moves don't embarrass Allah
but when that you stop by Jimmy Kimmel
Live earlier this week she did reveal
how he mortified her in front of her
celebrity crush Taylor Lautner was
coming over to the house pictures of him
and just of course she's coming we knew
that and then Taylor gets there and one
and his family as well so I was
researching about them - right just to
let you know cuz research
yeah yeah it's important so um then the
first thing he says to them is oh I was
just looking you guys up on the Internet
brutal right well John defended himself
to the show's guest host Lena wait a
father's point of views you know
everybody loves Taylor Lautner wouldn't
wouldn't he'd be flattered stars they're
just like us guys of course we'll be
here to keep you up to date on all
things John Travolta and his sweet
daughter Ella so be sure to keep it
locked on et until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens bye for now
you
[Music]